once in a while you see that balloon
that just got away and the question is
where does it go many end up in parks
and desert areas and now a Las Vegas
teen is on a mission to collect the
remnants 8 news now reporter Mary Jane
beliesa met up with him at Thule Springs
to show the impact on our environment
and our wildlife
what goes up must come down so went to
the desert villain project we I go out
and where most people don't hike with
every step and every turn Christian
Daniels is on the hunt for Miler
balloons does the Torches mistake them
for flowers and they'll eat them the
desert tortoises are already endangered
with
the constant building and loss of loss
of habitat and predation
and the Milo Bruins just cause another
disturbance with them Daniels first
started the desert balloon project in
early 2020 with a love for wildlife and
the environment he also picks up
balloons and trash along the way to keep
our desert clean having hiked over 900
miles he's collected over 3 000 balloons
so far and Counting they are everywhere
there's another one
there's a blue one right there just
within the first 10 minutes of our hike
we already found six Miler balloons most
of them stuck in between trees and
bushes like this with the shrinks
wrapped around the Twigs it doesn't
really matter where we go we just we can
just go somewhere and we'll find them
although mylar balloons are made of
nylon the foil layer can conduct
electricity and even cause power outages
desert tortoises also aren't the only
animals impacted birds and bighorn sheep
can also get tangled up in the strings
there was this one guy he sent me a
photo and like his pet donkey
uh actually ate a mylar balloon and it
died from it despite hiking all over the
valley Daniel says he can't get every
single Balloon by himself he hopes
others will join him on his cleanup and
help spread the word it brings me like a
lot of joy to educate the people